stunning news from hollywood overnight
actor chadwick boseman star of the
groundbreaking blockbuster black panther
has died in addition to playing the
comic book hero bozeman portrayed a
series of real-life
african-american icons bozeman taking on
many of those roles while privately
fighting colon cancer
chris martinez has more before he rose
to super stardom in black panther
chadwick boseman played 20th century
legends like jackie robinson and james
brown
boseman died after a four-year battle
with colon cancer
according to a statement calling him a
true fighter and saying he continued to
work while undergoing surgeries
and chemotherapy the statement said he
died at his los angeles home with his
wife and family by his side
black panther production company marvel
studios tweeted
our hearts are broken and our thoughts
are with chadwick boseman's family
your legacy will live on forever rest in
peace
when the film was released in 2018
bozeman was asked what it meant for him
to be the black panther
it me is is is taking on his own meaning
right now
i'm seeing that it's it's a cultural
experience
being the black panther the film became
one of the biggest box office hits of
all time
earning more than 1.3 billion dollars
worldwide
it was also a cultural milestone a
global blockbuster with a nearly
all black cast and black director
audiences had never seen
anything like it seeing them on the
screen it means that if i grow up and
play my card i can be on the stream just
like them give people an image
that people can people can look up to it
gives young young
african-american boys and girls the
opportunity to see themselves doing
something
great a year earlier bozeman dismissed
the idea that football player colin
kaepernicks taking a knee during the
national anthem
was unpatriotic we're in a period of
time where
people have to decide what is what is
patriotism
until black men are not brutalizing the
street and treated unfairly
i'm going to acknowledge that it's not
doing that
the south carolina-born actor's breakout
role wasn't 42
playing jackie robinson who broke the
color barrier in major league baseball
boseman died the same day major league
baseball celebrated jackie robinson
day chadwick boseman was 43.
for cbs this morning saturday chris
martinez
los angeles reaction to the death of
chadwick boseman is coming from both
hollywood
and washington bozeman's co-stars and
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden and his running mate kamala harris
offered their condolences on social
media later in the show we will talk to
dr
john lapook about the disease that took
the actor's life
a shock to me when i read it on social
media
my my alum howard university alumni
co-padre just a real loss worldwide
he did so much in a short span looking
back at those movies the impact they had
the people that he played
and he kept it so private yes yeah he
didn't tell anyone and that's why it was
so stunning when all of us
saw this last night but again we're
coming up with dr lapook very soon we'll
talk about chadwick boseman
yes